yeah welcome to the video um fall let's
go he fall in this blitz game what's a
great master should have some seen this
before efore against the GMS always more
tricky for me i'm not an not an
experienced before player who is this
anyway doesn't have a name in there GM
with a dutch flag but ok you must be
cautious with flags can be can it can be
anything ok so my idea was to play g4
and he prevented this with age 5 so now
we transpose to them fianchetto
variation again this coke set up let's
set up
it looks like healthy development for
white yeah it's complete development and
yeah probably castles nationals
if I go F for now hmm probably probably
i need to do that anyway
yeah i'm wondering if he may be can take
on g4 it's probably incorrect but let's
blitzes blitz on mmm 987 lk can just go
to g5 i will not be able to go without a
form probably so let's go
yeah this is some opposition relief
strategically desirable exchange for
black the only question is isn't this
very very slow kept the probably is but
is there some way to make use of that
the H for porn but I have no way to
pressurize it right on a three would be
nice but it is completely so just in a
bad spot maybe this move try to take on
c6 and put pressure on the d6 porn if it
looks a bit counterintuitive I know
making the g two bishops even looking
more stupid
but maybe it is an idea anyway he's got
some stupid pieces as well look at the
c8 bishop this is also very bad piece it
can never basically where should it move
to d7 young so half Mussolini my idea is
just rope d1 and then taking 1636 in d6
and what exactly is he doing against
this maybe I could have taken before but
there was always will be six and i
didn't want to want to deal with that
yeah this is a possibility he intends to
sacrifice and I'll take the spawn
so
let's scrap this porn hmm or 95 what are
you going to do really taking taking on
1 B 2 hmm
yeah I don't know ninety-five looks
tempting queen d tube should be five
also an idea but ok so try to play not
too too complicated
yes but I thought you would be in
trouble now yeah Tim moves and then I
wasn't so sure what he should but what
he plays after Queen c5 attacking the
here Quincy five attacks the the night
and then Queen a tribe meters that is
the problem if the night moves yeah it's
almost made it's not not a complete mate
but very very close if he takes for
example then the screen h5 made on f6
does not g6 yes and what now this queen
is a very very problematic piece rook be
one Queen a to this one it can go to f6
cyllage who looks like a terror square
how do I catch the screen should be a
should be possible in a way
maybe not maybe not
huh don't see a good move funny enough
my dear okay three perhaps weird
yeah of course I'm just fishing now I
really hope that I have something with
this bed king position but it didn't
materialize time morning
check
check-check
check
check
jet black it's on oh well yeah lucky at
the end somehow i think this this should
be the shrewdest shouldn't this be good
for right 25 is even the right move by
TM here there's something bad this looks
so promising is got the Queen on in a
bad spot let's let's check this I'm
really curious but I didn't didn't
really refuel it Quincy five was right
and now g5g rg5 is strong yes g5 and it
is strong because it controls the f6
square now threatening look fb1 trapping
the Queen this is very strong yeah I
forgot about the Jeep on aha this was
bad rook be one it's a terrible threat
and the only way to rescue the Queen a
screen before and then I can take and
play this move and this is this is
deadly cannot take yeah his wins wins
everything and what is he supposed to
play something like this this is very
strong yeah rg5 the g5 would have been
the move I still an interesting game but
here this was strong yeah well thanks
for watching